[Music]
hey what's up guys welcome to a sort of
a peek inside the mkbhd audio setup so
thumbs up if you like this today we're
taking a look at this the blue spark
microphone and yes it's orange okay now
that we've got that out the way this is
the microphone that you've seen or heard
me using in the past few videos and for
my experience with it this mic is
absolutely top-notch quality everything
about this microphone from the packaging
down to the body of the mic and the
chromed metal materials just screams
high quality now the most important
feature about this microphone is that
it's an xlr microphone and you can get
this xlr cable from just about anywhere
i'll leave a link in the description now
some of you guys might be staring at
your computer like whoa where's that
port i don't have that well don't fret
your computer probably does not have an
xlr port so
this here is the blue icicle any audio
interface will do and this will convert
from analog to digital which is xlr to
usb and the mic also comes with this
magnificent shock mount which is also
all metal and isolates the mic from
extra vibrations and stuff that can
cause noise and it comes with this sweet
pop filter it looks cool i didn't think
it would work but i mean i mean just
look at it but it actually has worked
surprisingly well
but just look at that body but seriously
check out the body on that that is
pretty classy right there but the most
important part of having a microphone
and why you spend all the money on it is
how it sounds so
how does it sound
you tell me you're listening to it right
now this is a blue spark plugged
directly in via the xlr cable to the
icicle directly into usb in my computer
and i think it sounds pretty good if you
want to know my opinion but obviously
you're listening to it if you listen to
this video in 1080p and you put
headphones on
you might be able to hear my roommate
breathing
in the background you should probably
keep that down this is a great
microphone for vocals because it is a
large diaphragm condenser microphone
which means it gets a full dynamic range
of your voice and also i'm using it with
the focus mode off right now so if you
have a particularly deep voice like
really deep voice you'll get all the
bass tones in your voice and it'll sound
really really rich and just come through
the microphone there is literally zero
background noise and that's thanks to it
first of all being really high quality
and also having a good uxb and xlr cable
so yeah i'd recommend this spark to just
about anyone who's getting into
entry-level xlr microphones i did a
video previously on my dac which is a
digital to analog converter it's another
audio thing you should probably check
out if you're into audio and a sweet
pair of headphones so there you go nice
pair of headphones nice
audio interface you pretty much set for
audio for me so far um unless you have
any other requests in the comments below
but yeah tell me how you think it sounds
either way i'll talk to you guys in the
next video the link to the lowest price
is in the description of this video
right next to the thumbs up button so
give it thumbs up if you enjoyed thanks
for watching guys
peace
[Music]
you